il y ait cette multiplication
d'intervention oui semble vouloir dire
que Vladimir Poutine est un peu comme
celui qui aurait oublié à chaque fois de
dire quelque chose qui reviendrait à
l'écran à l'antenne pour signifier pour
que les choses soient plus claires
d'ordinaire la parole de Poutine comme
celle d'un de n'importe quel j'allais
dire dictateur et quelque chose de
lapidaire de la conique pour que
précisément elles prennent elle est de
la valeur là effectivement vous avez une
séquence sous Poutine profite au fond de
chaque occasion alors là c'est un peu
particulier parce qu'il s'agit de rendre
hommage au pilote d'hélicoptère russe
qui ont été tués dans cette dans cette
affaire contrairement à ce que les plus
grosses il y a bien eu des soldats
russes de tuer mais on l'a vu c'était
hier je si je ne m'abuse ou devant un
parterre de de à la fois d'ingénieur et
de responsable formation d'enseignement
il avait pris la parole et donc les
prétextes sont divers et variés pour
justifier cette prise de parole dans le
même temps que dit-il il y a il y a
parfois des contradictions et pas des
minces il dit aucun vous l'avez cité
aucun soldat russe n'a été redéployé
dans cette affaire donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que c'était pas pris
au sérieux que la marge de Prigogine
vers Moscou au cours de laquelle privée
n'a pu parcourir sans encombre plus de
700 km n'était pas prise au sérieux
pourquoi dans ce cas-là il y a eu une
défense quand même à mosquare vous me
direz elle parlait dérisoire mais des
soldats ont déposé ont mis en place des
sacs de sable dans les rues de Moscou ce
qui parlaient dérisoires par rapport à
la menace ou bien
supposez donc cette menace n’était pas
réelle il y a toute une série de
contradictions y compris dans la dans la
parole de Poutine simplement l'idée que
le pouvoir vertical fonctionne toujours
tel que Poutine se le représente et bien
il faut en quelque sorte soumettre cette
hypothèse à la réaction du peuple et la
réaction du peuple on l'a vu Poutine dit
personne n'a soutenu les rebelles ni
narmée ni la population oui alors un
premier après tout l'inverse ce que dit
le patron de Wagner
comment comment Wagner aurait pu mener
cette opération s'il n'y avait pas un
intérêt ou un soutien derrière de la
part que ça soit de l'armée ou d'autres
services ça peut être guère ou le les
services de renseignement de l'armée
primo deuxièmement pas de pub pas de
population qui soutient en a vu les
images de Rostov sur le don où il y
avait un soutien tout simplement parce
que probablement que pour un certain
nombre de Russes on ne fait pas la
distinction entre Wagner et le pouvoir
russe d'autant que Poutine dit lui-même
ce sont des patriotes vous voyez comment
le le l'enfumage si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi fonctionne il s'agit au fond de
faire croire aux Russes que rien rien ne
s'est passé au fond
et que Poutine a toujours le pouvoir
à la limite je dirais c'est vrai dans la
mesure où les Russes sont eux-mêmes sont
persuadés que et c'est là aussi l'une
des l'une des choses les plus criantes
de toute cette guerre en
Ukraine les Russes sont persuadés que
même s'ils se passent des choses
inadmissible en Ukraine la stabilité du
pouvoir et le garant de la paix civile
et au fond le reste on ne veut pas le
savoir c'est à dire qu'il y a une
politique de l'autruche de la part de la
plupart des citoyens russes qui est
absolument bien sûr scandaleuses mais
qui correspond finalement à la fois à ce
que veut Poutine et à la propagande
générale même en temps de paix qui
l'organise si je vous suis bien elle
essaye de dégonfler l'affaire de
minimiser ce qui s'est passé ce week-end
pour passer le plus rapidement possible
à autre chose car il y a intérêt
Vladimir Poutine on a vu ces images
aussi de volody merzelinski le président
ukrainien qui lui on l'imagine entend
bien capitaliser là-dessus il s'est
rendu sur le front est hier annonçant de
nouvelles victoires la libération de
villages on aussi dans une guerre de
propagande ça on l'a vu dès les premiers
instants de ce conflit oui vous savez il
y a peu de guerres qui sont sans
propagande parce que sauf que celle-là
elle est suivie minute après minute
comme une série presque comme une série
télé oui les moyens la technologie
moderne le permet oui bien sûr parce que
il y a toujours vous savez la volonté
d'expliquer que le combat que l'on mène
et le plus juste et vous voyez bien
puisque vous parliez du début du conflit
vous voyez bien que il y a une
contradiction là encore dans la position
de Poutine Poutine se refuse à parler de
guerre très bien opération spéciale en
même temps il nous dit depuis le début
il nous Serigne depuis le début qu'il
faut chasser les nazis de Kiev mais
diable si la chose est si importante que
le dipotine bien sûr qu'une guerre se
justifie elle est même noble elle est
même parfaitement compréhensible et à
l'image de la grandeur russe alors
pourquoi d'un côté minimiser la chose
comme il le fait avec
l'affaire Wagner et d'un autre côté dire
il y a des traîtres parmi nous il y a
cette pérennité du régime néonazi entre
guillemets à Kiev donc voilà une
contradiction de plus il y a une chose
qu'on n'a pas entendu pour l'instant et
tout à l'heure je tiens à dire je me
suis avancé un peu rapidement mais une
chose qui était étonnante il n'y a pas
encore où il y aura pas j'en sais rien
mais de la part de Poutine d'allusion à
l'Occident or il serait très facile
il a semblé laissé dire que les
occidentaux étaient quand même de mèches
avec l'Ukraine dans cette affaire Joe
Biden lui-même a pris la parole dans la
foulée pour démentir oui ça paraît
logique simplement ce que je trouve
d'étonnant c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de la
part de Poutine un matraquage avec cet
argument qui consiste à dire au fond on
sait très bien que l'Occident veut la
chute la fin le l'effondrement de la
Russie et donc voilà cet argument qui
permettrait de réunir tout le monde y
compris les séditieux les factieux de de
trigogine en disant bah voilà nous
sommes tous des patriotes et au fond
nous avons été dupe nous avons été
bernés par une menace occidentale par
une menée plutôt une tentative de de
déstabilisation de la part de l'Occident
alors on va continuer